يصطادوا وضعوا كيف صعوبه في المعارك
الدائره وعلى اكثر من جبهه فلنلقي نظره
مشاهدينا على خريطه
الاشتباكات روسيا هاجمه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وايضا مدينه اديسا في الجنوب
عشرات الصواريخ ومنها صواريخ كاليبر اما
في دنيا شرقا السلطات المواليه لروسي
اعلنت انها دخلت مدينتي اوجلدار في المحور
الجنوبي للمقاطعه والسيطره موسكو على دار
قد تغير ميزان القوه وتسمح بتوجه
رؤوسنا
اما في موت يتقدم الروس الجنوب وشمالا في
اتجاه سبيرز بهدفه
الامدادات الاوكرانيه التي تاتي من غرب
البلاد واستدراج قوات قيام من مواقعها في
الزباروجيا وبالحديث عن الزفروجيه وتحديدا
في النصف الشمالي من المقاطعه هناك هجمات
روسيه اخرى محاوله للسيطره كامل المقاطعه
من اجل شن الهجوم على المدن الكبرى وبين
ما تحاول روسيا تنفيذ هذا الامر تريد
واشنطن من كياب التركيز على عمليه هجوميه
تكتيكيه لتحرير اكبر قدر ممكن او استعاده
اكبر قدر ممكن من الاراضي وهذا راي يؤيده
رئيس الاركان الامريكيه
تحاول اقناع الزلزكي بالامر وضروره
الابتعاد عن معارك الاستنزاف الضاريه مثل
خصوصا وان الغرب اعلن تسليم كياب دبابات
ابرامز واتشالنجر
هل ستصنعه
يؤكد ذلك
يرى بوضوح تقدم الروس الذين يعدلون الخطط
بعد ارسال الدبابات ويرون ايضا في
القرارات الاخيره تورطا مباشره في الحرب
على العموم كل هذا التقدم الروسي سبب من
اسبابه هو مشاركه قوات ذاك ناربي حسب
وثيقه استخباراتيه عسكريه اوكرانيه
تهديد فريد بحسب الوثيقه لكن هناك تهديد
اخر يمكنه ان يتسبب في انهيار القوات
الاوكرانيه بالكامل تتحدث هنا عن الفساد
سبايدر بالعربي
في اوكرانيا هددت قياده الفيلق بنشر
بيانات قد تتسبب في انهيار القوات
الاوكرانيه بالكامل
الطبيه المقدمه لاوكرانيا لتحاول قياده
الفيلق اقالتها عده مرات لكن احتفظت
بمنصبها بسبب تهديداتها وهذه القصه تنقلنا
لصوره الاكبر من الفساد المستشار في
اوكرانيا تحت هذه الطائره و خلال الاسبوع
الماضي فقط اقيل او استقال 15 مسؤولا
بسببي قضايا فساد نائب وزير التنميه
البلديات من المقالين تهمته تلقي رشوه
قيمتها 400,000$
سهله الرجل لابرا معقود شراء معدات
ومولدات باسعار المبالغ فيها في الوقت
الذي تعاني فيه اوكرانيا بسبب قصف روسيا
لمشاهات الطاقه
اقيل هو الاخر بين ما استقال نائب وزير
الدفاع
الشابوبالوك الذي كان مسؤولا عن الدعم
اللوجستيه للقوات المسلحه ومساعده مديري
الاداره الرئاسيه كاريلو تيمو شينكو
الاخير يشرف مثلا على مشاريع اعادته
امر انسانيه جاءت من اجله مساعده غربيه
ومنها سيارات دفعنا الرباعي منحتها جينر
الموتورز لكن الرجل استخدمها بشكل شخص
الدفاع بالتربح من عقود المشتريات
الغذائيه الخاصه بالجيش صحيفه تركيا
المواد الغذائيه باسعار اعلى مرتين الى
ثلاث مرات من اسعارها في المساجد ومن خلال
شركه واجهه
رغم ذلك نفى وزير الدفاع والاكسي ارز نيكو
الامر برره بي مجرد خطا فني في اسعار
المواد الغذائيه المتداوله كل هذه التهم
جعلت الرئيس الاوكراني يخرج ويتحدث عن
الامر وعدم مكرر منذ الانتخابات التي جاءت
به الى كرسه الحالي في 2019
يا برنس